gone Must Die those three words are
played in repeat on Yoshi hero tashi's
head for the entire span of Hunter
Hunter and we know this because in a
2012 interview Togashi revealed a very
key aspect of his writing process for
Hunter Hunter which is that he actively
writes with the determination to kill
his protagonist at any given time and he
even go so far as to write alternate Arc
endings where the antagonists win and
what usually happens from there is that
Togashi takes that and he takes the more
standard shown and ending and he marries
them somewhere in the middle where the
main protagonist never die however it's
still a very effective method for
creating tension I think that a lot of
authors particularly in the Shan genre
are very afraid of harming much less
killing their protagonists but when it
comes to yoshihiro Tashi what we have
Happening Here is a case of fictional
characters facing off against their own
author as he constructs the plot with
every intention of ending their
fictional existence and it's their job
to get out of it for the most part I
think this method Works beautifully and
it really helps to convey just how
dangerous the world of hun Hunter is
however there are also some times where
I think it goes a bit bit far and plays
to the detriment of the series but there
is absolutely no better example of this
than gone and for the purposes of this
video we are going to rename Hunter
Hunter 2 gone must die because that's
the Mantra that Togashi has been writing
the story with and phase four of the
hunter exam is where Togashi really
starts to implement his soon to be
trademark writing style this was the
phase on zevel island where the
remaining candidates needed to secure
the badge of their randomly assigned
Target so thinking about it from
togashi's perspective what would be the
most deliberate and most efficient way
to kill gone one natural idea would be
to give hisoka gon's number and then
have gon be targeted by the main
antagonist but that's not quite
efficient enough because then gon would
be occupied with someone else and he
would be actively running from danger
now what Togashi wants is for gon to be
walking straight into danger and that's
why he gave gone he soak his number so
that gon would be forced into a
confrontation with the biggest baddest
clownman on the island gon was even
excited which I think mirrors togashi's
excitement in having written it because
really you could not have written it
better than this this is a worst case
scenario for gone and it really does
demand that you turn the next page and
the one after that and so on until you
figure out exactly how he's going to get
out of this also this video was
sponsored by honkai impact third the
phenomenal NextGen 3D crossplatform game
available for Android iOS and PC it's an
immersive open World Experience
featuring a whole ton of different ways
to play stunning Graphics engaging voice
acting and all of the bosses to beat and
one character who can do just that is
Herer of sentience known to be the most
beautiful and strong strongest in the
universe she has one of my personal
favorite character designs in the game
which I would describe as Sleek yet
devastating and now you can get her
completely free H much like the UI
upgrade for the latest version which
features significantly increased storage
optimization allowing players to save up
to 6 Gigabytes which is a literal
GameChanger and also we have a new
character for you her name is Gro an
artist who paints her enemies through
the medium of defeat as well as a very
handy laser saber and she comes clad in
a beautiful new battles suit there's
also a lot of upcoming holiday bonuses
for Christmas and New Year's Day you can
join the holiday events and get 15 plls
for free along with a whole ton of other
amazing stuff so you can and should
download honkai impact third using my
link in the description and you can use
the code yatas Senti to get a whole ton
of rewards including 30 crystals
2,888 aite and an SSS trial card option
it's a genuinely fun game and I have to
give a special thanks to honkai impact
third for sponsoring this channel
because this is what allows us to
produce more fictional Hunter content
for you so give it a go but for now it's
back to you me also in case you're
unaware hisoka's number was 44 for being
a bit of a spooky number in Japanese
culture because it's pronounced as she
which also means death so gon wasn't
just walking into death he was walking
straight into double death so gon was
doomed from the moment this happened
Togashi wrode gone into a corner of
death that no amount of creative shown
and protagonist thinking could get him
out of which is emphasized through the
artwork portray hisoka as a terrifying
insurmountable Supernatural presence and
you know there is very potentially an
old outline of Hunter Hunter sitting
somewhere amongst arashi's notes where
gone dies right here and now he walks
into the lion's den and he gets eaten
but because we're in a Shona manga we
need to do not that and this is where we
Salvage the situation by turning hisoka
into a very different kind of Predator
one who does still want to kill gone but
under some different personal
circumstances from a narrative
perspective Hoku is like going bumper
bowling you get all of the excitement of
throwing the ball wildly at the pins but
you're always safe and sure to hit them
whenever he soakers around the tension
is still there because he's an unknown
quantity and he could snap at any time
but ultimately gone is always going to
be okay and most of what I've said here
also carries over to Heaven's Arena but
the final phase of the hunter exam needs
to be addressed first it's a very unique
and strange tournament format that
Togashi constructed for this phase and I
think we can dissect why that was if we
work backwards I don't think Togashi
started with this idea I think what we
did was we remember the Mantra what was
it everyone gone must die and so what's
the most efficient way to make that
happen well if we had a heart set on a
tournament then that would be to make it
a deathmatch tournament and pair gone up
against an unbeatable opponent in the
very first round who absolutely
obliterates him excellent now how do we
take that and shape it into a more shown
and friendly story well what we do is we
put the bumpers up again gone gets to
walk straight into the lion's den once
more in order to find Hanzo however the
tournament format is tweaked firstly
there's no killing allowed it's the
first person to admit defeat and then
the entire structure of a tournament is
flipped on its head as the losers
progress and the winners drop out to be
awarded with a shiny hunter's license so
Hanzo could still snap gone like a
KitKat but that's the one thing he's not
allowed to do so we know that gon's not
going to die here but there's still an
insane amount of tension because we also
have no idea how he's going to overcome
the situation and gone doesn't end up
with some magical out either he gets
pretty thoroughly brutalized even having
his left arm broken which starts the
trend of gon arm injuries in fact look
at it this way every time gon sustains
an arm injury that's almost certainly an
occasion where Togashi thought to kill
him and I also want to note that gone
doesn't desire death but he's not afraid
of it either he was very willing to die
in this fight against Hanzo as well as
almost every scenario going forward
which makes gone the perfect character
for this sort of writing style because
he's just so simple and Reckless so
finding situations that are far above
his pay grade is not difficult at all
such as during Heaven's Arena where gone
learned a modicum of n control and
immediately disobeyed Wing's edict
because and I quote sorry Wing I just
can't wait I got a fight which is the n
equivalent of attending one University
lecture and then believing that you have
a degree this is another situation where
Togashi wrote Gone walking straight into
death there was no clever Shonen
solution to this gone was simply
outmatched and he paid the price for
this which was another broken arm but
gon's life and thus our story was saved
due to putting some bumpers up which was
the framework of Heaven's Arena which is
that it operates on a pointbase system
so Togashi came up with the recipe for
this particular gone Death Cake but then
removed an ingredient to result in
another fantastic Showcase of legitimate
tension and consequences that Hunter
Hunter is well known for weirdly enough
the gone versus Hoka fight is one of the
only instances that doesn't fall into
this framework because by this point we
knew what we were in for the format of
Heaven's Arena was well explored and we
understood hisoka's desires regarding
gone and that's why this fight is
probably the most stereotypical shown in
fighting Hunter Hunter which isn't a bad
thing in fact it's probably the reason
why it's so revered and such an easy way
to hook new people into the world
because it's just a brilliant Showcase
of M character progression and in both
anime versions it's an absolute
spectacle and feast For The Senses I was
actually watching the 1999 version of it
the other day and that animation is held
up shockingly well for something that
was made a quarter of a century ago then
for York New City we actually take a bit
of a break from gone and in a future
video it might be fun to examine how
kopa fares with this writing style
because he is every bit as much the
protagonist of Hunter Hunter as gone is
now but even with that Togashi still
finds every opportunity he can to place
gone Immortal danger because that boy
just keeps keeps running into that their
Phantom troop again he doesn't escape
without punishment he gets another arm
injury but the bumpers in this situation
end up being the value that gon's life
presents it's not anything that gon
himself does it's more that he's a very
important piece in finding kopa but it's
Greed Island that shows just how far
Togashi is willing to go so we've had
our kopa break now let's get back to our
Mantra gone must die and on Greed
Islands the most straightforward way of
achieving that would be to force gone
into conflict with the most powerful
figure on the island being Razer even
more so than gen through the actual
antagonist of the Ark because Razer is
essentially a God in the game so how do
we work backwards from this well instead
of having gone straight up fight Razer
and try to find a horrible way to make
that work instead what we're going to do
is play dodgeball but dodgeball that's
not very exciting so how do we keep the
tension well what we're going to do is
we're going to make it life or death
dodgeball if you get hit you don't just
lose the game you lose your life and
Razer is no joke before the match even
starts he demon demonstrates that he can
blow a man's head clean off and even
though Razer is a friend of gon's father
he goes into this with the resolve and
perhaps even the intent to kill gone and
there is nothing stopping him from doing
just that other than the rules of
dodgeball and even then gon is still
thoroughly IL equipped to deal with the
situation but to bring us back from
killing him we implement the bumpers of
kiloa and again Hoka it's very much a
team effort which does seem like maybe a
bit of a cop out but togashi's not done
yet to make up for this during the same
AR Togashi sends God once more into
certain death against genr and this time
he's all alone gone versus genthru is a
heavily underrated fight even by me at
times but it's probably the most even
fight in the whole series and I actually
consider it to be gon's finest moment in
terms of combat because it takes the
major elements of gone being his
tenacity Hunter's Instinct and N
proficiency and then pushes all of it to
its very limits where at the end he
comes out satisfyingly Victorious but
remember the Mantra gone Must Die how do
we make that happen we're going to send
him into the woods all alone and then
there's going to be a master n serial
killer is not good by All rights gone
should have been blown to bits and well
he partially was which is the brilliant
reversal that happens here gen through
actually fights with the logic that a
standard Shonen would follow he assumes
that the main character wasn't just
going to become permanently wounded and
disfigured simply in order to defeat him
the bad guy of the Ark but as we've
established Togashi is not only super
keen on killing gone but gone is more
than willing to walk straight into his
death as well which is again through his
one p at failing in this fight his
typical standard Shonen logic leads him
straight into gon trap and if Togashi
had not spent the entire series
perpetually thinking about different
ways to kill gone then I don't think we
would have gotten this dramatically
potent of an outcome however this is
where I think things start to unravel a
bit this is where we begin to have a bit
of a difficult time reconciling
togashi's desires with what he believes
are the expectations of the audience if
it was up to Togashi I think that gone
would have permanently lost his hand
here as well as kept his other injuries
which to quote bisy when she's asking to
heal gone could you heal his hands and
throat actually just fix everything
that's wrong with him so there was a lot
wrong with that boy and sadly only the
physical parts got fixed but for the
first and not the last time in Hunter
Hunter Togashi had to resort to every
right as nightmare a de of sex MAA to
get gone back into the shape that
readers would expect him to return to I
say that but again this is what Togashi
expects that the readers would expect
there's two layers to go through there
and look it's fine because this does
take place within the constructs of the
Greed Island game so you can do
otherwise unusual things that you
wouldn't be able to do in reality but
this is a little taste of what's to come
because the Chimera ant talk is where
Togashi took gone as far as he could to
the brink of death and without even
going into the reasons why gon did what
he did he once again willingly steps
into a situation where he's prepared to
lose his life and of course this time he
loses a whole arm as well as nuse but he
really should have lost everything
including his life because we're talking
about yoshihiro Togashi at probably his
most nihilistic phase of life and in
retrospect we know that this was
effectively wrapping up gone story so I
think that Togashi was seriously
prepared to kill him this time and So
Gone was written into a situation that
would have been impossible to get out of
without some sort of nen God stepping in
and just magically making it go away
which would go on to happen with nanika
and gone received something of a happy
ending rather than the Bleak ending that
I can't help but feel Togashi would have
really wanted to deliver which is the
only time in Hunter Hunter to me that
the Togashi desire and expectation
balance didn't quite work out he gets a
pass on Greed Island again it's a game
weird things can happen but to this day
I feel like it's a bit stock standard
that we found a way to give Ghana
happily ever after after the Chimera
Anar however that doesn't take away from
how powerful dramatic sorrowful tensions
some and literally all of the feelings
that Togashi was able to construct in
the fight against Pito as well as the
fight against genr Raza the Phantom
troop gido Hanzo and Hoka all of this
was made possible through tashi's
formula of deliberately writing the
series with the intent to kill gun and
then finding the most Creative Solutions
to change the world around him to get
out of it and that is one of the simple
but masterful aspects that allows Hunter
Hunter to stand out from every other
Shonen ever created